des patients avec des problèmes
de santé mentale. Résultat,
certains passendndndndndndndndn.
Davide Gentile.
- Depuis des décennies,
La S
qui vivent avec la maladie
mentale. Mais cet automne,
la propriétaire Rosanne
Desjardins a décidé de
vendre son entrepr
résident de La Sittelle
- Oui, oui, je suis très bien.
On a eu du fun...
On mangeait beaucoup ici.
- Les huit résidents,
acoioioioioioioioioioioioioioio.
- C'est Mario, en bas, qui me
dit ça d d dit : "La maison
est vendue, il faut déménager".
J'ai dit : non, non, non!
- L'établissnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnne
et bien tenu. Elleaiaiait voulu
continuer, mais se dit submergée
par les exigences du réseau
ROSANNE DESJARDINS, propriétaire
Résidence La Slelele
- Le gouvernement, il demande...
des permis, demande ci, demande
- Plusieurs propriétaires de
lieux rgrgrgrgement en santé
mentale prennent la même
décision, ce qui aggrave
On compte maintenant
1100 personnes en attente
d'une placanananananananananana,
dont 630 uniquement
sur l'île de Montréal.
Dr AMINE SAADI, dir. CIUSSS
- On a de plus en plus de cas
complexes,dededede plus en plus
une population vieillissante,sse
des soins adaptés.
- Le réseau tente de développer
de nouvelles places plus
adaptées. Mais en attetststststt
à attendre plus longtemps
dans les départements
de psychiatrie.
- Je vous diu u u u u u u u u u,
de façon générale, je vais
parler de façon très générale,
on tourne autour de... 17 % dest
en essai dans nos hopitaux.
- En clair, ça veut dire
que 12 à 17 % des lits
de psychiatrie sont occupés
par des patienisisisisisisisisi.
Dr OLIVIER FARMER, Association
- Il y a peut-être cinq
ou six ans, quanititititit
un jeune, par exemple,
qui avait besoin d'une foyer
avec la travailleuse sociale
et, gé à à à à à à l'intérieur
de trois à six semaines,
on trouvait quelque chose.des d,
cinq, six, sept huit mois.
- Ce qui transforme
certains patients en
résidents à long terme
- 200  j j j j j jours,
400 jours. Des gens qui
sont bien, des gens qui ont
des longues so g g g g g gens
qui habitent à l'hôpital,
qui habitent à l'hôpital.
- Et parce que ces lits
de psychiatrie sont occupés
aux prises avec des problèmes
enenenenenentale doivent
prendre leur mal en patience
sur des civières à l'urgence
un autre problème qui contribue
à l'engorgement record
de cet automne au Québec.
Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréa